the iris is still closed on any new
stargate series but is it about to
reopen
and what do we know about amazon's
influence at mgm
this is sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so i recently did a video on how
stargate is about to come back and that
amazon has big plans for this franchise
but i just want to do a couple of short
little videos just to explain a little
bit more detail and throw in a few
little bits of new information that i've
been able to glean from a source that i
have that works closely with mgm
so first of all i have to explain that
amazon's deal to buy mgm is not actually
finalized this 8.5 billion deal plus
amazon have agreed to take on maybe 3
billion worth of debt that mgm currently
has is not actually finalized it still
has to be approved by regulators in the
united states and one of those
regulators the federal trade commission
isn't amazon's biggest fan
they think amazon are slightly
crooks and that they have had
tactics and quite aggressive business
tactics in the past that have not
necessarily been conducive to fair
competition
but
it is generally accepted the deal will
go through however going back to
september this year it was still being
dragged through the federal trade
commission and it may be a few months
yet but i'm going to talk about in
another video when i tell you when do i
think stargate is actually going to hit
our screens because there is a plan
that's for another video so amazon's
influencer mgm is pretty much already
entrenched
amazon had direct influence when the
executive of scripted material changed
back in march and that was actually a
month or two before the sale was even
firmly announced
when steve stark left after nearly a
decade at mgm and was placed by michael
wright amazon had direct influence on
that choice and actually had direct
influence on michael wright getting the
role
he's seen as amazon as having far more
influence on combining projects like
movies tv series games things
because they want stargate to become a
multimedia franchise
they look at what marvel have done with
movies tv series games all these sort of
things and how they've merged them
together how they've all of those
different projects become canon and they
add to each other
and they want to replicate that with not
just stargate but other franchises as
well mike hopkins a high ranking
executive at amazon said when they
bought mgm
the real financial value of purchasing
mgm
is the treasure trove of intellectual
properties in the deep catalogue that we
plan to reimagine
and develop together with mgm's talented
team
i can confirm that stargate is firmly in
the sights of amazon that they have
identified it as the sleeping giant of
sci-fi
and that they want to get this project
up and running as quickly as possible
however that announcement is not going
to happen until amazon's
control of mgm is finally authorized
a few eyes to dot a few t's to cross i
have also said that it has been
confirmed to me that there is no big
changes planned for the storyline of
stargate there's been a project for the
last four years that brad wright has
been working on and that is planning to
continue
but that is another video
so how much influence does amazon have
on mgm right now
it's pretty much total
the mgm channel is on amazon prime
that gives them a significant amount of
control it shouldn't surprise you that
stargate is being pulled from servers
like hulu in america
because that is amazon putting all of
its eggs in their basket
it shouldn't also surprise you that
that's happening considering what we now
know or what we think we now know about
amazon's plans for this franchise now
i'm going to do a couple of little
videos just like this bite size to
explain what i've been told a little bit
more detail if you are new to the
channel please like and subscribe hit
that bell notification please go to the
discord server the link is in the
description and you can chat with other
people about what you think is going to
be happening with stargate and other
sci-fi projects
you can also go and join us on facebook
the link is also in the description
where i dump all of the information it's
completely open you can go talk about
anything you want on there um please
just don't take advantage of that and
put stuff on there that's not
appropriate
don't get me kicked off facebook please
but
go and have that conversation and also
leave a comment tell me what you think
about amazon's influence over mgm and
amazon's influence and plans for
projects like stargate
the next video is all about brad wright
and his plans for stargate and how those
plans
might have just changed quite a lot
since may
thanks so much
see you next time